so we have that to look forward to all
right a great concert coming up this
weekend benefits a great cause Santa Jam
is uh going to happen Sunday at Pearl
theater inside Palms Casino Resort here
to tell us more about it is a familiar
voice from 95.5 The Bull Mojo Roberts
thanks for being here today thanks for
having me so let's talk about Santa Jam
what's the concept and who benefits from
it well it's a first year event we're
doing uh benefiting St Jude Children's
Research Hospital an organization that
we have worked closely with through many
different fundraising events throughout
the year we do a radiothon it's actually
going to be next week so we thought you
know Nashville loved St Jude they always
their artists are always so quick to
support and give us you know autographed
items for the radiothon let's put a
concert on and benefit St Jude so
quickly Tyler Hubbard of Florida Georgia
Line signed up the guy who has the
number one song actually this week
Jackson Dean will be there Matt Stell uh
Daniel Bradbury from The Voice or so
many artists Ashley cook and a newcomer
Shane profit all playing and it's only
20 bucks that's a strong lineup right
right and again all of that benefits St
Jude's hospital so we get to have a good
time and of course we'll have some some
auction things happening on site and a
few other things for the family yes it
is a family event you can bring your
kids and uh for that price point I mean
oh no that's no concert is 20 bucks
these days isn't that the truth that's
fantastic especially with Headliners
like that where can people get tickets
95.5thebull.com or go to Ticketmaster
and search you know Santa jam and you'll
find it right and still some tickets
available right now there are still some
tickets and they still start at 20 bucks
so take advantage while you can because
you know the Cowboys are coming to town
for NFR and once they hit the ground
it's probably sold out I'll tell you
what man yeah that's right yes sir 20
bucks all right so once again it's
coming up this Sunday yes sir this
Sunday and uh it's at the Pearl theater
inside the palms and afterwards for the
21 plus side of it we're going to have
an after party celebrating Jackson
Dean's number one single upstairs at the
new ghost bar inside the Palms how fun
all right so there's the family section
you know the concert's family friendly
and then for those 21 and up they can
celebrate afterwards well it's a school
night so by 10 there's
yeah makes sense Mojo thanks for being
here really appreciate it and thanks for
putting on such a great concert for a
good cause hope to see you there all
right